[Music]
coming up on 610 on your Finally Friday
what's driving you crazy well these are
not complete freeway closures of the
I-15 near the spaghetti wall but there
are three upcoming weekends where you
might want to stay away from the freeway
now this is all part of the Nevada
Department of transportation's repaving
project on the 15 from the spaghetti
Bowl all the way up to Craig Road and it
starts tonight at 8. the Northbound side
of the 15 is going to be down to one
lane from the 95 up to Washington now
yeah that's only about a mile but that
one lane only is going to be in place
all weekend scheduled to run until five
Monday morning now there is no work
scheduled for next weekend but hang on
tight for the next two weekends in a row
after that so from 8pm Friday night July
7th until 5 a.m Monday July 10th both
directions of the 15 going to be down to
one lane only at Lake Mead then from 8
P.M Friday July 14th until 5 a.m Monday
July 17th the I-15 is going to be down
to one lane on the southbound side for
that mile from Washington down to the
U.S 95. you might want to write yourself
a reminder about all of these closures
which you can go over in the online
version of this story where we've also
got suggested workarounds it's
8newsnow.com click traffic then driving
you crazy buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone join the
driving you crazy conversation at
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com